[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURIAN CLEMENCE:
Last month, Farrah
launched her new book, "The
Discomfort Zone," which
I'm sure you've seen by now.
And she's here to tell
us a little bit more
about that today.
So let's first delve a little
bit into her, and her journey,
and what brought her here today.
So hello.
Thanks for joining us today.
FARRAH STORR: Biographies
are so weird because you
feel like you're going to
be vastly underwhelming now.
But yeah, that's my
sheen, but you know--
LAURIAN CLEMENCE: Absolutely.
Well--
FARRAH STORR: I
always think people
should-- we should talk
about their failures
before-- because it's just all
about your successes, isn't it?
And actually, it's like,
actually, Farrah Storr
didn't get into Oxford.
Farrah Storr bombed
out at this job.
But-- we'll do that next time.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE: That's fine.
Well, we'll cover it.
We'll definitely
cover it because I
think that's really
important as well.
So tell us about your early
years at "Cosmopolitan."
When you first
started back in 2015,
you'd come from
"Women's Health."
You had successfully
risen up from the trenches
as in your launch.
And what made you
move on to "Cosmo"
after such a successful
time at that magazine?
FARRAH STORR:
Well, so I launched
"Women's Health" with kind of--
it was really challenging.
So I never thought I
wanted to be an editor.
I thought I wanted
to be a writer.
And editorships do not
come up very often.
And so when "Women's
Health" came up,
it was not a typical editorship.
It was kind of two
people, three people,
including me, in a room.
We had six weeks to get
this magazine together,
and we had minimal resources.
And we had to sell 100,000
copies from issue 1.
And so we had massive
expectations on us.
And against all the
odds somehow, we
managed to make a big
success of that magazine.
And so by the time
I'd been doing
that magazine for
3 and 1/2 years,
I remember, it was in
June, I said to my husband,
I said, wow, I said,
I've had three years
where it's just been
challenged after challenge
after challenge.
And I said, this
honestly feels--
I think it was June the 15th.
I said, this honestly
feels like it's
comfortable for the
first time in my life.
Like, the sales were
doing really well.
I had a wonderful team.
It was great.
And then I got a
message from my CEO.
She was on holiday.
And usually, if you get
a message from your CEO,
oh, come and see me,
you're about to get fired.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE:
Something's up.
FARRAH STORR: Yeah.
And I thought,
well, that can't be.
And basically, she
said, look, how do you
feel about "Cosmopolitan"?
And the truth is, "Cosmo"
had been one of those brands
which I'd always
applied for jobs
there, early on in my career,
and I'd never got the jobs.
I'd never actually got
beyond the second interview.
And I always felt that I
just wasn't a "Cosmo" girl.
And actually, that's why, now,
I'm very clear on actually,
there is no "Cosmo" girl.
Do you know what mean?
It's just a state of mind.
And actually, that's why
we don't have a "Cosmo"
tone of voice in the magazine.
We have divergent
voices within there.
And so I think that was
part of that which was like,
OK, now, I get to be
editor of this magazine.
But also, because
the magazine needed
to go through a load of changes.
I remember my CEO
said, look, we need
to just give it a freshen up.
We need to make
it more attractive
to millennials, who, of course,
are the hardest group to reach.
And I went home.
And I was like, oh, I just
don't know about this.
And then in the end,
I decided, well,
challenge had always
served me very well
throughout my entire life.
When I looked back,
my greatest successes
had come from when I'd
had challenging times.
And so I took the job.
And it was challenging.
It was really challenging.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE: Definitely.
And I would say in
light of the fact
that the publishing industry
is a challenge at the moment
as well, often, Google's blamed
for a lot of the challenges
that the publishing
industry has.
How do you measure your
success based on that?
If your sales are
down one month,
how do you determine,
for example,
that it's an industry
problem, perhaps, the changing
readership that
you've experienced?
Or is it just the
issue that month,
that you think, oh, perhaps we
should have changed the person
on the front of the
cover, or the tone
should have been different?
FARRAH STORR: Well,
traditionally,
that's what you do.
So you look at your
sales for every month,
and you go, OK,
well, this was down,
and so it's something to
do with the cover star.
And covers are really important.
They're probably the most
important marketing tool
you have at your disposal,
more now than ever before.
But actually, "Cosmo" is a
really unique brand in that
our sales are pretty static.
Occasionally, we'll
have a big spike.
So the Tess Holliday
cover recently, we
had a huge spike there.
But usually, they are pretty
static and they're high.
You know, we sell over
300,000 copies a year,
so still huge numbers.
So for me, as an
editor, of course
I've got to look at the sales.
You have to look commercially.
Do people still want to
spend money with you?
But for me, it's
changing readership.
So there's nothing
more gratifying for me
when, actually,
I'll meet everyone.
And of course, you get to meet
and interact with your readers
much more now.
I mean, I get about 40
messages a day on Instagram,
the different ages.
So for me, what's
successful about "Cosmo" is
I can reach everyone from a
16-year-old right up to a woman
in their kind of late 50s.
And I think dialogue.
I think one of the things for
"Cosmopolitan," when I joined,
one of the first
things I did was I
looked back at what
"Cosmo" had been
when it was at its peak, which
was in the '60s and '70s.
And it had always been
about starting conversations
amongst people, never
having a point of view,
because that's not the
point of journalism
unless you're a columnist.
But it was about
putting the information
out there and then people
making their own decisions.
And so for me, one of
the most gratifying--
and I think it's one of the
best metrics of success for me--
is, does "Cosmopolitan"
start conversations?
And does it help people to
start thinking differently
about issues when they're
very blinkered in their views?
And then the other thing--
and this is very unique
to "Cosmo"--
is we have two schemes,
which I'm so proud of.
One is Cosmopolitan
Houses, where
we house young creatives,
who can't, perhaps,
afford to come to London.
We will house them.
We charge minimal rent.
We house them in these amazing
houses in Central London.
And then we do a sex
education program in schools.
So all that-- you
know, where there
is a real hole in
the school curriculum
is sex ed, consent,
online grooming.
And a metric of success
for that, for example,
we just did a pilot over
the summer on 700 kids.
And we got-- I think,
from one school that
was 82% of young boys said they
had no idea what consent meant.
So the change actually is
another metric success.
It doesn't bring money in.
But actually, I would argue--
it seems very grandiose, but
it genuinely changes lives.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE: And you're
blazing the trail for something
that "Cosmo" originally has
never been known for, which
is quite significant in itself.
So that's brilliant.
And going back to
the cover star--
I'm sure a few people in
this room would have seen--
the disruption and dialogue
created from the Tess Holliday
cover from September,
what was it like going--
did you expect that reaction
from the cover, first of all?
I know you would have
expected a little bit.
But what was it like
seeing from everybody,
sort of dividing a room,
how they reacted to it, how
going on Piers Morgan, you
had to lean into that fear
to go in there and
defend your decision?
And how, importantly, did
you convince those around you
to follow your
lead and your team?
Because often, when
you make that decision,
was your team with you
on it the whole way?
How did that work for you?
FARRAH STORR: Well, I have
a team who doesn't always
agree with me.
And actually, I employ them
deliberately because of that.
I always say to them,
just because I'm the boss,
just because I'm at
the top doesn't mean
I'm right about everything.
So we often have discussions
rather than arguments about,
is this right.
And sometimes I will go
back on what I've said.
And I'll go, it's a fair cop.
I'm completely wrong.
My instinct is
always to push things
to almost breaking point.
And so I like having more
measured people on the team
to go, well, if you do that,
this is going to happen.
Of course, often, we go
with the thing that's
going to spark the debate.
Because for me,
sometimes that overrides.
And Tess was-- well,
actually, the truth about Tess
is, we didn't think it would
cause the kind of success
and the fury that it did.
Because I'd had Rebel
Wilson on the cover.
It had done very, very well.
We didn't hear
anything about it.
We had Ashley
Graham on the cover,
who is a plus-size model.
And so actually,
I didn't think--
I thought there may
be a little bit.
But actually, I remember when
that issue went to press,
we had a far more
contentious story
in the mix, which
was we had a story
about a young brilliant writer,
who we'd just discovered,
who wrote about her
experience of rape.
And actually, it was
quite an incredible piece.
It is online so
you should read it,
where she came to
us with a story.
She said, my rape was traumatic.
It was terrible.
However, she said, I dealt
with it in my own way.
And she said her
problems began when
she told-- she was at
Columbia University-- she
told the sisterhood.
And the sisterhood
said, you need
to be the face of this now.
And she said, that's
not my choice.
I do not want to do this.
And she said, when
they turned on her,
it was worse than the rape.
So when we decided to publish
that-- because, of course,
the people on the team
going, [INHALES]----
LAURIAN CLEMENCE: All right.
FARRAH STORR: Yep.
We thought that would
certainly would spark debate.
But actually, that
would cause the furor.
And it didn't, not at all.
It so happened that it was the
Tess cover, which is amazing,
because I think what it
revealed more than anything
is we have a real
problem with fat
in a way I had never expected.
When we put the cover
up on social media,
I remember, the first thing,
my features director phoned me.
And she said, we've got
all of these people, some
of them consumers, saying going
to cancel my subscription,
not going to read
this, which is a shame,
because they never
read the story.
And Tess was on there
not because of her size.
Tess was on there because,
against all the odds--
she suffered a
lifetime of abuse.
She grew up in a trailer.
She's 5 foot 3, and
she's 300 pounds.
She still became a
very successful model.
So that's the "Cosmo" girl is
kind of that's scrappiness,
hustling.
Yeah.
So that, we thought,
oh, my word.
And then, of course,
Piers Morgan happened.
And then we had all the
over-- and I cannot tell you,
the overwhelming response.
In our office, as
you can imagine,
everything is by email.
The general public, when
they get in touch with us,
it's by email.
It's through
Instagram or Twitter.
The phone was ringing
every single day.
And it was from older women.
And this was interesting.
It was from older
women, who were
kind of my age,
slightly older, saying,
I haven't picked up
"Cosmo" in years.
This picture, this image,
made me pick it up,
and it made me
really think about,
if I had seen a woman like
this when I was growing up--
and I feel like this because
I suffered disordered
eating most of my life.
They go, I wonder how different
my life would have been
and some of the choices I made.
So that was the really
interesting thing about it.
And it's turned out to be
incredibly successful, which
is great.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE: Just great.
And as you say,
it's getting people
to pick it up, look
at what's inside--
FARRAH STORR: Read it, yeah.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE:
And read what she
has to say, other than just
her image on the front--
FARRAH STORR: Absolutely, yeah.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE: --which
is a huge success to you.
So she also, Tess Holliday,
publicly endorsed your book.
FARRAH STORR: Yes, yes.
After all of that, I said,
here, here's a book if you've
got any time to read it.
But yeah.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE: Now,
it's your turn, exactly.
And that's the hustle, isn't it?
So we'll talk a
little bit about.
FARRAH STORR: Yes.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE:
For those in the room
that don't know much
about your book yet,
would you mind just giving
us a brief introduction
as to what it's about?
FARRAH STORR: Yeah,
so the book is about--
I mean, if it was like
an elevator pitch,
it's essentially that life is
tough, but you are tougher.
And actually, the only way that
you discover you are tougher
is by putting yourself--
stepping really into
the discomfort zone
and challenging yourself.
So that's the very
short end of it, really.
I mean, you asked
me earlier, did you
just come up with the idea?
Well, not really.
You know, they say
it takes a lifetime
to write your first book
because you're always
thinking about it.
And for me, every success
I'd had in my life,
when I look down
the tunnel my life,
had been from when I'd
had difficult times,
success had followed.
And so I thought, A, it's
something worth sharing,
and I think, B, it
happened at a moment
in culture, which is
really interesting,
because, of course, we
are going through a period
of high anxiety, but also a
period of intense coddling.
And we see this--
in our education system, it's
happening in our universities.
But particularly, in a lot
of the liberal elite American
universities, we
see this coddling
of students, safe spaces.
And I think the thing is--
and we know this--
exposure therapy does work.
The studies are there.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE: It
builds resilience.
FARRAH STORR: It
And it's like it's not that
things become less scary.
They don't.
But you become braver by
exposing yourself bit by bit
to them.
And I just think it's an
important message rather than--
I think at the moment it's like,
well, if something scares you,
don't worry, you
don't have to do it.
And actually, I would challenge
that and say, you can do it,
but you need to go
in with a plan of how
you're going to tackle this.
Yeah.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE: So let's
talk a little bit about stress
because that came through
in your book as well.
We told, as you say, with
the coddling and so forth--
we have too much
stress in our lives.
We need to disengage, detox.
And cortisol is
really bad for you.
But you have a different
theory on that in your book.
And actually, stress can
be really good for us.
So can you explain a
little bit what that means?
FARRAH STORR: Well, yeah.
And of course, it's the
right amount of stress.
I mean, I think sometimes
people are like,
so you're saying stress is good.
And I'm saying, well,
the right amount.
And actually, I've always
believed that human beings
are meant to carry a load.
A little bit of struggle
is what we are built for.
And we know this from
our caveman days.
Adrenaline, it's
flight or fright.
The thing is is--
and I think this is what
hopefully the book explains--
is you need to know
what to do with fear.
And I think that's the
thing, fear or stress
or whatever we call it.
And I've found this.
It's like all the physiological
sensations we have,
which are sweaty palms,
the kind of stomach that
feels it's been macramed,
the beating heart,
these are things we are told,
it's because you're scared.
Don't worry.
And actually, they are
identical physiological symptoms
to when you're excited.
But we're very rarely told that.
And there are again
copious studies
on that, which is if
you tell yourself--
and you only have nanoseconds
in which to do this, by the way.
If you tell yourself-- and this
is what I did before I went
on to--
I say talk-- to argue
with Piers Morgan.
I felt all of those sensations
because actually, you're
in this green room.
And there's a big screen.
And he was building up, going,
oh, my god, the woman behind
this, she's coming in to
answer some questions.
And so I felt all
of those things.
But instead of thinking,
oh, my god, I'm terrified,
it was like, no, I'm
in a challenged state.
And it's amazing.
When you tell yourself
that, your body changes.
Your lungs enlarge.
Your blood flows quicker
through your body.
And you become sharper
and I say smarter.
Your thinking becomes sharper.
And that was all fleeing
woolly mammoths and whatnot.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE:
Back in the days.
FARRAH STORR: Yeah,
but I don't think
we're told to do that enough.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE: Yeah, I mean,
you said one of the key things
that you did that was probably
the most fearful thing is when
you had to first
walk onto a stage
when it was 10,000
people, 20,000 people.
FARRAH STORR: 20,000 people.
But I didn't know that.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE:
And you didn't know.
And you felt like you
were going to blackout.
There's that feeling
where suddenly you think,
I'm gonna freeze,
and there's not
going to be anything I can
say, and I'm sweaty palms,
adrenaline.
So what did you do to pivot
off that situation when
you were suddenly confronted
with this massive crowd,
and you had to do
something about it?
FARRAH STORR: Well, I think
that there were lots of things.
So actually, that scenario--
most of my life is
just quite chaotic.
I agreed to do an interview,
as you are doing now,
with a tech founder.
And it was at a big summit.
And at that point,
I hadn't really
done much public speaking.
I'd probably done it to as
big an audience as this.
And I was like, yeah,
I'll interview him.
Don't worry.
And I remember--
because there were
lots of different
rooms at this summit.
And I remember we
were on at 4 o'clock.
And I remember walking towards
the area it was supposed to be,
and there were just these
crowds and crowds of people.
Because it's all-- you
don't really see the stage.
I had to walk up these stairs
and through these tunnels.
And I was with this guy,
who, as you would imagine,
is lovely, but very quiet.
And then somebody
said to us-- well,
actually, it was the organizer
who ran backstage and said,
there's a massive crowd.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
FARRAH STORR: Yeah,
it's 20,000 people.
And the worst thing
was, he said--
I'll never forget this.
He goes, I want you to just go
out there and be rock stars.
It's like, I'm a
middle-aged journalist.
He's, like, just
a quiet tech guy.
And then he's like,
and I need you
to stand there for 15 seconds
because we need some pictures.
And then you can see this
big counter counting down.
And so it was like, oh, my god.
And we kind of looked
at one another--
LAURIAN CLEMENCE: Terrifying.
FARRAH STORR: Yeah.
We didn't know what
we're going to do.
And we walked out there.
And because-- even
though I'd only
spoken in front of
small crowds before,
one of the things I'm always
terrified of in public speaking
is not public
speaking per se, even
though I used to think the
whole experience was awful.
It's not, of course.
There are moments within it.
And one of my big
things is always
the moment when the
crowd is kind of talking,
and you have to get
their attention.
It's very difficult to do.
And I remember, even when
I would give small talks,
one of the things
that I had learned
by watching lots
of YouTube videos
was, great speakers always
diverted the attention away
from themselves and they
put it on the audience.
Because everyone loves talking
about themselves, right?
Or thinking about themselves.
And so they ask a
question, or they instruct
the audience to do something.
And because I had done that a
number of times, gut instinct
is basically
pattern recognition.
So I kind of knew that.
And so when I walked in front
of the crowd, I remember,
we were walking up the stairs.
And I said to Sean,
I said, let's them
to take-- let's get a selfie.
Let's take a massive selfie.
And so we were stood in
front of this huge crowd.
And I remember just
saying, you know,
this is what we're going
to do and instructing them.
And they did it.
They did it.
They turned their lights on.
And we got this amazing picture.
And then they were very
subdued, and it all began.
But it was because I had had--
and in the book, I call them
brief moments of discomfort.
Because no one situation is
ever completely uncomfortable.
It's just not true.
But there will be moments.
And those are what stop you
from delving into the discomfort
zone because you think
the whole thing is horrid.
And because I had identified,
with public speaking,
what mine was, and I'd
come up with a plan--
because all we want is
the illusion of control--
it saved me.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE: That was it.
You just pivoted on the spot.
That's brilliant.
You also explain a
little bit in your book
about how failure works and
how important failure is.
Being at Google, a lot of
us are scared of failure
because we work at such
a brilliant company.
But you've done a lot
of research about it.
And you've also, in
your book, really
beautifully created a lot
of businesses and leaders
as your examples.
So can you run us through
some of the failure
stories of our decade
and our lifetime
that we should all think of
when we are doing something
that's important to us?
FARRAH STORR: Well,
I'm sure Google
would say it's had
lots of failures,
but actually, that's
actually helped them.
Amazon founder,
Jeff Bezos, Bezos--
however you pronounce it--
is obsessed with it,
absolutely obsessed with it.
And I think all of his
shareholder letters,
he talks about failure.
And I remember-- I'm
paraphrasing now.
But they had that phone.
I think it was a phone,
or was it the Amazon Fire?
LAURIAN CLEMENCE:
The Fire Stick, yeah.
FARRAH STORR: And
he said, if you
think that was a colossal
failure, don't worry,
we've got even bigger
failures lined up.
People were like, he's crazy.
But of course, the thing is--
and you work in the tech world.
There are two types of
failure, aren't there?
There's failure by complete
carelessness, which
is the wrong sort of failure.
And then there is smart
failure, which is-- well,
we are heading into the unknown,
so if you want to be perfect--
there's no information there.
So smart failure is going, well,
we're heading into the unknown.
There's no information
available to me.
So we're probably
going to fail, which
is why you should fail small
and do it incrementally.
The thing is, I
think-- and I think
this is the bit that
people sometimes
get wrong is looking back on the
failure, like, why did it fail.
I mean, the chap
that I interviewed,
so Sean Rad, who created
Tinder, his big thing
was, I asked myself why
a minimum five times.
And by combing through
why did it get wrong,
you then have this really
unique piece of information
that nobody else has.
The other thing about
failure, of course,
is that I think most
people have an idea of who
they think they are.
We go through life
thinking, I'm a good person,
or I'm a creative.
And failure, which is why
it scares a lot of us,
it's suddenly you're
confronted with,
I'm not the person I
thought I was perhaps.
And people don't like that.
But of course, I
would say, you're not.
But now you know you're
not, you can work on it.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE:
So almost, failing
is actually better
in the beginning,
because you learn so much about
it, than just pure success.
So if you want to be
successful straightaway,
maybe that doesn't set you
up for success later in life.
FARRAH STORR: Yeah, I think so.
I think it is to be embraced.
I mean, look, and
in Japan, they have
totally a different methodology
around how you treat failure
with kids, whereas
in the Western world,
when you're at school--
and I don't know if that's
the same in South Africa.
When you're at school, the child
that gets the answer right,
they put their hand up, and
they are kind of decorated
for they got it right.
In Japan, the child that
gets the answer wrong
is the one that
they all focus on.
And as a group--
and this is Eastern
thinking-- but as a group,
they all come together
without stigma or humiliation.
They analyze, with the
child, why did it not work?
And they work together on
coming up with the right answer.
So they all learn through
this child's failure.
So it's very, very different.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE:
It's brilliant.
So could you give us a
scenario, in that case,
in terms of failure and what's
happened to you in your life?
I know you talk a little
bit about some of the things
you failed at.
You were a sprinter for
a long time in your life.
FARRAH STORR: Right, yes.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE:
Which is amazing.
And also, you got a sort of
crushing rejection letter.
How has that set you up now
for what you're doing next?
FARRAH STORR: Oh, I mean, god,
I've had so many failures.
So I think with the
sprinting, I mean,
actually, the minute I started
not succeeding and winning
races is when I gave up
sprinting, which was a mistake.
But as a 13-year-old, I
wasn't told any different.
It was just I'm not winning.
I'm not perfect.
This isn't for me anymore.
So that was a mistake.
I mean, actually, when
I was in Australia,
I had a job which
I really failed at.
I mean, I was terrible at it.
I really was.
I'd jumped too soon.
I'd taken a promotion
I wasn't ready for.
And I remember when I
was failing at the job,
I do what most people do,
which is, I was like, well,
I blame my colleagues,
and I blame the boss.
It was a bad boss.
But of course, even if that's
true-- and it wasn't actually.
She was an excellent boss.
Even if that's true, I don't
believe in blaming other people
because you can't control that.
The only thing you can
control is your own actions.
And so that job was
really important
because it told me,
A, my limitations.
But also with that job--
and there's a little bit
about this in the book--
is that it was what
I refer to as a slog.
So everything I did, no matter
how many hours I put in,
it never got any better.
It never changed.
The color of that job
was always kind of black.
I just couldn't do it.
But then you have
other jobs, which are,
you put all the hours
in, and it feels so hard,
but there is
incremental movement.
And that's a challenging job.
And so I think it's
really important
to hang on to the memory
of the really terrible job
because then, you
can compare it.
When you're in a tough job,
you can go, is it a slog,
or is it a grind?
And a grind, of course,
is what most of life is.
It's what is on
the way to success.
So I think jobs that you
think you've failed at,
they're incredibly useful.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE: Definitely.
And then you often, I
suppose, related to that,
you address feedback
in your book a lot.
And who you get it from is
obviously very important.
So how do you do feedback?
I mean, you obviously have
a massive team at "Cosmo."
You've got different
mentors in your life.
But how do you
curate that feedback?
And who do you trust
to ask for that
and get a solid answer that you
know is going to work for you,
and you can take yourself
to the next level?
FARRAH STORR: Well, I don't
believe in mentors for a start.
I just think
mentorships can be--
I believe in momentary
mentors, so you can get people.
I think amazing people
come into your life.
You get them for a
very short window,
and you're very lucky if you
get them for a short window.
And you should take what you
can and give when you can.
But I think the whole idea of
mentors for a very long period,
I've never found personally they
are great because what ends up
is you sit down--
they can go on for an
indeterminate length of time.
And all that happens
is you just end up
offloading and just moaning.
And actually,
mentorship-- I mean,
I call it having a care coach,
which is identifying someone--
if it's for your career,
somebody in your environment,
possibly not on your
team, actually-- so I
give feedback to my team,
but I give it every day.
Every day, it's constant.
And every day, they're probably
put into their discomfort zone
because I give them feedback
all the time on every project.
But actually, for me, at
work, I identified somebody
who knew my job and
what it entailed.
So she could make a judgment.
She was informed on my job.
But she wasn't in my immediate
team and she wasn't a peer.
Because I think you have
to be really careful.
Somebody said to me recently,
all feedback is good.
And I was like,
yeah, but it depends
who the feedback is from.
And they're like, no, no,
no, all feedback is good.
And I was like,
let's not be naive.
Some people will
have an agenda when
they're giving your feedback.
So you need to
choose somebody who
I think is outside of your
department, who doesn't
challenge your status, or you
don't challenge their status,
very important.
And then I think
what you need to do
is you need to be
very specific in what
do you want from this person,
so you don't just go--
I mean, I get this.
You must get this.
People go and just
pick your brain.
Well, about what?
And that's the same as
success, when people go,
I want to be famous, or
I want to be successful.
It's so vague.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE: How?
FARRAH STORR: How?
And so you put in time
with your care coach.
And you probably only
do it once a month
or however much you need it.
And it can change.
It can be once a week If you're
going through a difficult time.
And then it can
change over time.
But you put in a very specific
amount of time, so say,
20 minutes.
And you do it outside
of the work environment.
And in preparation, you come up
with no more than three things,
which are super, super specific
about what you want to know.
So it could be, what am I like
when I am doing public speaking
in the first 10 minutes, say.
Be specific, because then
they can be specific back
in what they give you.
And I think you let
them go after a while.
I don't think you get to
keep hold of that person.
But they're really,
really important.
And I think the other
thing is, nobody
likes receiving feedback.
But also people don't
like giving feedback.
Again, it goes back
to the caveman days.
You would be isolated.
We see on "Big Brother" when
people go, just being honest.
They get excluded.
And so I think when people
are giving you feedback,
you've got to smile.
You've got to say thank you.
You've got to make it
as easy as possible
for them to be able to give
you the feedback as well.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE: Absolutely.
And you talk a little bit
about the three things
that you envision and visualize
when you go and do something.
And that's your
inner mentor talking.
You train yourself to
be your own mentor.
Because, as you say,
they're quite momentary.
You go along life, and
different people enter your life
for different reasons.
But how do you become your
own mentor, so no matter
what, that little
voice in your head
is the right one
speaking to you,
and you're not having the
other voice in your head
telling you not to do it
because you're too scared?
So how do you
separate those two?
FARRAH STORR: Well, I
mean, look, it's very hard.
And it takes lots
and lots of practice.
And it goes back
to, again, I mean,
I think when we have
something difficult
approaching-- say it's a job
interview-- we're actually
brilliant at
visualization, but we're
catastrophizing things.
So actually, most of us, when
we think about a job interview,
say, we think about
everything that will go wrong,
what happens when they
ask me the question,
I don't have the answer.
What happens when I walk in?
I take the wrong seat.
What happens when I get
sweat patches under my shirt?
All of these things.
So we are brilliant
at visualization.
And of course, there
is some research
to show that, actually,
it can manifest.
So what you have
to do is you have
to do the very thing which
is the opposite, which
is you have to--
say you're coming
for an interview at Google.
You can do everything
right down to--
it sounds quite
stalkerish, but looking
at the building on Google Maps.
You can imagine what it's like
when you walk through the door.
I mean, Wayne Rooney
does this or used
to do this before a match.
He would do everything from what
did the socks feel like on him,
what does it feel like
when he scored the goal,
what music is he listening
to before he goes
and he's got the match that day.
And you have to do it every
day, in the build-up to your job
interview, say.
You've got to keep on doing it.
Because the urge is so
strong to catastrophize
that your inner mentor,
you've got to build it up.
So start with five minutes,
10 minutes visualizing,
until, by the time you
come to said job interview,
you've changed your state.
You're in a challenged state.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE: I've got it.
Yeah, exactly.
That's brilliant.
And the question that most
authors get, no matter when
they've done their first
book-- what's next for you?
I mean you've written
this amazing book.
It's still got a lot of legs.
You've still got a
lot to do with it.
But what is next for you?
Do you see yourself
doing something similar
in the future, writing another
book like this perhaps?
FARRAH STORR: I don't think so.
My editor's here.
And I was so bad
with my deadline.
I don't think so.
Not for the time--
I think the thing is--
I mean, ironically, this did
throw me into my discomfort
zone because I'd also had
a big full-on job which
was going through a period
of monumental change.
So I had to be so
disciplined with this.
It was very, very
early mornings.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE: A passion
project of note too.
FARRAH STORR: Yeah.
Yeah, really.
And I think sometimes
when you're a writer,
you think, oh, it's
easy to write a book.
Well, of course,
it's very difficult.
And if you're an editor
as well, you are writing,
and then you're editing,
and then you're writing,
and then you're editing again.
And the feedback is
very hard to get.
So my editor gave me lots of
feedback, which was amazing.
But it's hard to take.
I think the next
thing for me is--
I mean, look, I love "Cosmo."
I think, for me, it is the most
interesting female media brand,
because I can talk about
the issues that count.
The big thing for me
will be with the brand
is building more of
the housing scheme.
That's a huge thing.
The sex education
project is huge.
And there will be other socially
motivated projects coming up.
So those are the things that
are my real passion project.
And the magazine.
You know, I love journalism.
I think it's a really
important time for journalism.
I think journalists need to
keep their head about them
at the moment.
And I think in a
world of outrage,
there needs to be a place
where you go, look, this
is what's happening in culture.
Here's all the information.
Now, go forth and figure it out.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE:
That's brilliant.
Thank you.
FARRAH STORR: You're welcome.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE: I want
to open up to the floor,
to people who wanted
to ask some questions,
potentially-- we've
got a few minutes--
and then perhaps
some book signings.
FARRAH STORR: Yes, of course.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE: That
would be brilliant.
So any questions to start?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So my question is
basically around--
so when you're trying to figure
out for yourself what you're
good at, what
you're not good at,
I feel like, for me, I always
concentrate on the things
that I'm doing really badly
or that I need to focus on.
But I can't get myself to
think about the positives, what
I can do really well.
So how would you
reframe that situation
to try and understand,
what are the things
that you are good at?
FARRAH STORR: Sorry.
That microphone is outstanding.
Was it a Dictaphone with
a microphone on top of it?
Well, it's very hard, isn't it?
Because the natural tendency
is to think about everything
that you're terrible at.
And actually, what
I would say is,
you may be surprised
what you're good at.
So again, if you
have a care coach,
or you have somebody
who you trust
who is not your mum or your
brother or you know, ask them.
Give me five things
that I excel at.
And I guarantee, some
of them will cross over
what you thought or what
you hoped you were good at.
But there's nothing better than
having it from another source.
And actually, I would say get
it from about three sources,
because you'll see
overlap in, actually,
what people see you
are really good at.
And then again,
it's the specifics.
It's like, I didn't realize I
was good at analytical work.
Then, again, once you've
had that confirmation,
you just need to focus on that.
So it's very hard.
I mean, most people do.
And people always say to
me, I get imposter syndrome.
I kind of feel
imposter syndrome can
be a really good
thing because when
you feel an imposter-- of
course, if you were sat back,
and you were the boss
with a cigar and your feet
up on the table and you
didn't feel an impostor,
well, then, where's the
drive to learn everything?
And so actually, whenever
my team get new jobs,
they always say before they
leave, I'm really scared.
And I'm like, that's
absolutely how you should feel,
because you're going
to the next level.
And if you're not scared
about your next move,
you don't feel an
imposter, I would
challenge whether you are
going into the right job.
So I think, actually, you can
harness imposter syndrome.
If you have imposter
syndrome, what do you do?
Well, you look for
all the information
so that you never
get caught out.
And ultimately, that's
what makes you brilliant.
Always have the answers.
AUDIENCE: And as a
follow-up, so when you go
into a negotiation-- like,
say you want to get a raise
on your salary or more
scope in your job--
how do you use both the
negatives and the positives
to approach that
kind of conversation?
FARRAH STORR:
Well, I don't think
you'd bring that into a
pay negotiation actually.
I think pay negotiation
is about hustle,
which we talked about earlier.
And I think what
a lot of people--
I mean, it's interesting.
Steve Jobs said--
again, I'm paraphrasing.
He's like, all I ever did
in life was ask, and I got.
Well, he's Steve Jobs.
Of course he got, because
people wanted, ultimately,
something from him.
And so I think hustle, which
is what ultimately a pay
negotiation is, it's not
about, I think I deserve more.
And we've been told this.
I'm good at this.
I think I deserve more money.
That's not enough.
You have to hustle that person.
So you have to go, I
want this, but here's
what I'm going to give you.
That's what true hustle is.
The best hustlers
in life, they almost
give you more than what
you want from them.
So I would say if you have
to go into pay negotiation,
you say, look, this is what I
would like, rather than this
is what I deserve, because
they may not feel the same.
But you need to have
a massive list of,
here's what I'm going
to give you for that.
Most people, that's
very seductive.
Does that help?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It's good.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for the session.
Really interesting.
I think at Google,
there's no lack--
and that's everything.
We don't have a lack
of opportunities
to do things and put ourselves
in the discomfort zone,
I believe.
I wanted to ask you, how was
your decision-making process
when you have to decide whether
an opportunity is really
a good one, in the sense that
to set yourself for success?
Because I guess there are many
situations where you could
go into discomfort
zones, arguably,
but actually not be really
necessarily prepared.
So if you haven't thought it
through, it could be, in a way,
too risky.
I don't know.
Your thoughts about that.
FARRAH STORR: Well, it's
interesting, isn't it?
I mean, I think
first of all, you
have to have real self-awareness
about what does a discomfort
zone look like for you.
So for example, I
would never go, oh,
the CEO job has
come up, brilliant,
I'll take that,
because it's too big.
The gulf is too massive.
And actually, I think stepping
into your discomfort zone,
it's only really a good thing
to do if you have a plan.
So this goes back
to the idea of,
can I control the situation?
So there's that.
It's like, if I take
this next opportunity,
do I have a plan of how I'm
going to get through it?
What I don't do--
and this is a
personal thing-- is
I don't do where,
again, we were told,
do all the positives
and all the negatives,
because the natural impetus is
to look at all the negatives
and stop.
And actually, what
I tend to do is
I tend to say yes
to a lot of things
and then I figure out the plan.
I go, do I think I
can roughly do this?
Do I have the skills to do it?
Or if I stretch my
skills a little bit,
would I be able to do it?
And if the answer is yes,
then I say yes quite quickly,
because I tend to find the
more you think about things,
you'll catastrophize it.
I mean, it's just our nature.
You know, unless
you're a narcissist,
and there's a lot
of those around,
in which you'll just say yes,
but you won't be able to do it.
And you will fail ultimately.
So I think when it comes
to new opportunities, what
I do is I look at them.
I'm very aware of
what my skills are,
which is why you've got to go
back to, what am I good at,
what am I not so great at.
If I push them a
bit, can I do this?
Which is why I took
"Cosmo," because I'd already
been an editor.
I had vaguely the skill
set to do the job.
But I definitely don't
do negative and positive
because I tend to find the list
of the negatives is so big.
And that's what you think about.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
And as a small follow-up,
I feel personally
that with age, we tend
to have less ability
to go into the discomfort zone,
maybe because the stakes are
higher, or we are more afraid
of risking what we have,
while thinking of
myself as a student,
it would be such an easy thing
to go and jump into projects.
How did you experience
something like that?
Do you have a way of
dealing with that?
FARRAH STORR: Well, it depends.
I mean, you're right.
I think as you get older, a
lot of people go, oh, it's age.
But actually, it's because
the stakes are usually higher.
You have a family, or
you know what I mean--
the life you have built,
the stakes are much higher.
So I think that's why,
when you're older,
you're a bit more cautious.
I don't think it's
actually age per se.
I also think there is a lot of
thought around younger people--
and I'm talking about iGen
and millennials largely.
So I'm Gen X. Millennials
grew up during the self-esteem
movement.
So they're told, quite well
meaning, you can do anything,
whereas my generation
was not told that.
The whole self-esteem movement
hadn't really reached me.
So I actually think now--
I don't know if
you'd have asked me
that question 20 years ago
whether I would have agreed.
Because actually, I
think as you're older,
you have all the expertise.
So actually, you're in a much
better position to do it.
I don't think it's the
idealism of youth per se.
But I do think
younger people now,
they are built slightly
differently to us.
So that's why they're
perhaps more willing.
And also, actually, if
you're a millennial,
you kind of haven't
got anything to lose.
Because I really feel for them.
They've got, like,
no chance of a job
for life, mortgage, no pension.
So actually, I think that's why
they're also less risk averse.
Because it's like, well,
what have I got to lose?
Whereas for us--
you're younger than me.
But for me, say, I'm lucky.
I've got a mortgage.
I've got a pension.
So I think they're a really
interesting generation right
now, really interesting.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE: We
have another question.
AUDIENCE: So you might have
answered this question.
I mean, I think I'm still
part of the generation that
just came out of uni and got
into a company at Google.
So I'd like to take you
a little bit back in time
and maybe give some advice
to your younger self.
What would be the
first thing that you
would tell her going forward?
FARRAH STORR: Probably
what the book is about.
Because when I was growing
up, I was a middle child.
I was very quiet.
And I didn't always--
apart from the running.
But then the running,
once I started losing,
I just left because I
was scared of failure.
I think it's about you are
much tougher than you think.
And actually, you
have to do things.
You've got to go
through obstacles
because obstacles are amazing.
They teach you,
again, about yourself
and what your limitations are.
And I think when I was
much younger, going back
when I was 10 to 13, I
was a really quiet child
and quite nervy
about certain things.
I think it's that.
It's like, trust
yourself, that actually,
when you go through the tough
stuff, that's absolutely
the right thing to do.
And you will come
out changed, and you
will learn incredible
things about yourself.
I think most people think when
they go through obstacles,
it's going to be
debilitating, and you'll
learn about all the
things you're terrible at.
But actually, once you know
what you're not good at,
you can make a plan
of how to do it.
So I think that's it.
I think I would have taken
more risks as a young child.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for sharing.
My question is with failure
and self-confidence,
I find that I personally
like to succeed and win.
And I find the more I win,
the more self-confident I am.
But the more I fail at stuff,
the less self-confident I am.
So how do you get
into the discomfort
zone and self-confidence?
Because I feel like
it's inversely related.
FARRAH STORR: So sorry.
What was the question?
So--
AUDIENCE: Entering discomfort
zones and self-confidence.
FARRAH STORR: Keeping
your self-confidence.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
FARRAH STORR:
Yeah, I mean, look,
that's really hard, which is
why you have to-- because what
you're saying is, if you go
into your discomfort zone
and you fail, then your
self-confidence takes a knock.
But I think it goes back
to how do you see failure.
And actually, if you
fail at it, but you
went in with the right
frame of mind, which is,
let's make this up.
I'm going to start
this business.
There is no information
about this business,
so I'm going to have
to take the leap.
You failed for
the right reasons.
And that's what you
have to tell yourself.
It's like, well, did I fail?
Yeah, but look at
all this information.
I mean, there are so
many businesses that fail
but actually, they then
went on to greater success
because they looked
at the failure.
So I think what you have
to do is when you step
into your discomfort zone--
and if it doesn't
work out for you,
you have to analyze what
went wrong, but also
not beat yourself up
about the failure.
I think this is a cultural
shift about, well,
the failure was for
the right reasons.
And so in theory, it shouldn't
impact your self-esteem.
And I think it's changing.
I think a lot of the
world now, if you fail--
I think, certainly
in my day, people
would go-- they'd
keep away from you.
It's like a bad smell.
People don't like
being near failure.
I think it's very different now.
I think it's starting to change.
And people are seeing it as
brave, unless, of course,
you fail, because you threw
yourself into your discomfort
zone without any plan.
But then you wouldn't do that.
You know what?
You would go in with
a really clear plan
of why you're doing it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm just curious, because you've
talked a lot about experiences
within the workplace.
But was there anything
during your career
that you pursued outside of
work, where you purposefully
put yourself outside
of your comfort zone
to further your development?
Say, something that helped
both in the workplace,
but you pursued outside of work.
FARRAH STORR: Well,
I suppose it's
helped my personal development.
So when I was 21, I had a best
friend, a male best friend.
We were so close.
Never fancied him.
But we were so close.
And I remember--
and he never had
a girlfriend the whole time.
And I remember one
day just waking up,
and he'd met someone
called Farrah, weirdly.
And he'd met her at Glastonbury.
And there was
something in me that
could sense that it was
a moment of opportunity.
I don't know.
I was just overcome
by, actually,
I'm in love with this guy, and
actually, if I don't say it--
it goes back to the failure.
It's like, I could fail.
He could turn around
and go, I'm just
not interested in you, Farrah.
But actually, I'd have failed
for the right reasons because I
hadn't--
I didn't know how
he felt at all.
And actually, I remember.
He was at Glastonbury.
It was on the Saturday.
And I said, I want you
to come back to London.
And I didn't know what
he was going to say.
And he was like, why?
And I said, I just
need to see you.
And he'd just met this girl.
And bless him.
He got on the train.
He came back.
And I opened the door.
And we had a kiss.
And he's my husband now.
Do you know what I mean?
So I took a massive
chance on that.
It could have worked
terribly, and I
could have lost the
best friend of my life
because we were so close.
And I would have.
I think instinctively you know
what is right for yourself.
You just have to trust yourself.
I don't there's any such
thing as a right decision.
But you make the decision right.
I really believe in that.
And I think I knew when he met
that girl that I was probably
going to have to
retreat from his life.
And so I just went with--
I'm very good at just going
after what I want and saying.
And what's the worst
that's going to happen?
So does that-- probably far more
detail than you need to know,
but--
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
LAURIAN CLEMENCE:
That's brilliant.
Do we have time for one more?
One more?
We're good.
We can do some signings.
Thank you so much.
It was really good to have you.
[APPLAUSE]